good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Kevin and is chairman and Senior
Partner of the UK and Middle East Coast
I'm delighted to welcome this afternoon
Prime Minister Sir ministers and
represented the media to our offices
here in Bank my place I know you don't
want to hear from me just a few quick
words on PwC we employ 22,000 people in
the UK and over the last year we've
recruited two and a half thousand school
leavers apprentices and graduates to our
buildings 25 offices across the UK it's
a special week for us because this week
we open a new office in Bradford to
provide high quality jobs to the
community they're like all business
leaders we crave certainty and stability
and therefore I'm delighted to ask Prime
Minister to the platform now speak about
brexit thank you very much
thank you very much I became Prime
Minister almost three years ago
immediately after the British people
voted to leave the European Union my aim
was and is to deliver brexit and help
our country move beyond the division of
the referendum and into a better future
a country that works for everyone
where everyone has the chance to get on
in life and to go as far as their own
talent and hard work can take them that
is a goal that I believe can still unite
our country
I knew delivering grexit was not going
to be simple or straightforward the
result of 2016 was decisive but it was
close the challenge of taking brexit
from the simplicity of the choice on the
ballot paper to the complexity of
resetting that country's relationship
with 27 of its nearest neighbors was
always going to be huge while it has
proved even harder than I anticipated I
continue to believe that the best way to
make a successor brexit is to negotiate
a good exit deal with the EU as the
basis of a new deep and special
partnership for the future that was my
pitch to be leader of the Conservative
Party and Prime Minister that is what I
set out in my Lancaster House speech and
that was what my party's election
manifesto said in 2017 that is in
essence what the Labour Party's election
manifesto state is to and over 80% of
the electorate backed parties which
stood to deliver brexit by leaving with
a deal we've worked hard to deliver that
but we have not yet managed it I've
tried everything I possibly can to find
a way through it's true that initially I
wanted to achieve this predominantly on
the back of conservative and
votes in our parliamentary system that
is simply how you normally get things
done
I thought the changes MPs demanded I
offered to give up the job I loved
earlier than I would like and on 29th of
March the day we were meant to leave the
EU if just 30 MPs had voted differently
we would have passed the withdrawal
agreement and we would be leaving the EU
but it was not enough so I took the
difficult decision to try to reach a
cross-party deal and brexit many MPs on
both sides were unsettled by this but I
believe it was the right thing to do we
engaged in six weeks of serious talks
with the opposition offering to
compromise but in the end those talks
were not enough for labour to reach an
agreement with us but I do not think
that means we should give up the House
of Commons voted to trigger article 50
and the majority of MPs say they want to
deliver the result of the referendum so
I think we need to help them find a way
and I believe there is now one last
chance to do that I've listened to
concerns from across the political
spectrum I've done all I can to address
them and today I'm making a serious
offer to MPs across Parliament a new
brexit deal as part of that deal I will
continue to make the case for the
Conservative Party to be united behind a
policy that can deliver
grexit nine out of ten Conservative MPs
have already given the withdrawal
agreement they're backing and I want to
reach out to every single one of my
colleagues to make the very best offer I
can to them we came together around an
amendment from sir Graham Brady and this
gave rise to the work on alternative
arrangements to the backstop although
it's not possible for those to replace
the backstop and withdrawal agreement we
can start the work now to ensure they
are a viable alternative so as part of
the New Mexico
we will place the government under a
legal obligation to seek to conclude
alternative arrangements by December
2020 so that we can avoid any need for
the backstop coming into force
I've also listened to unionist concerns
about the backstop so the new brexit
deal goes further to address these it
will commit that should the backstop
come into force the government will
ensure that Great Britain will stay
aligned with Northern Ireland we will
prohibit the proposal that a future
government could split Northern Ireland
off from the UK's customs territory and
we will deliver on commitments to Vall
island in the December 2017 joint report
in fall we will implement paragraph 50
of the joint report in law the Northern
Ireland Assembly and executive will have
to give their consent on a cross
community basis so new regulations which
are padded to the backstop and we will
work with our competence and supply
partners on how these commitments
should be entrenched in law this near
exit delay will contain significant
further changes to protect the economic
and constitutional integrity of the
United Kingdom and deliver brexit it is
a bespoke solution that answers the
unique concerns of all parts of
community in Northern Ireland but the
reality is that after three attempts to
secure parliamentary agreement we will
not leave the European Union unless we
have a deal that will curb on
cross wider cross-party support and that
is why I sat down with the opposition
I've been serious about listening to
views across the house throughout this
process that's why I went to Labour MP
easily Sunanda and Gareth Snell put
forward their proposals to get
Parliament the bigger say in the next
phase it goes
I listen to them so the new brexit deal
will set out in law that the House of
Commons will approve the UK's objectives
for the negotiations on our future
relationship with the EU and they will
approve the treaties governing that
relationship before the government signs
them and while the talks with the
opposition did not reach a comprehensive
agreement we did make significant
progress in a number of areas like on
workers rights I'm absolutely committed
to the UK continuing to leave the way on
this issue but I understand people who
want to guarantees and I'm happy to give
them so the new brexit deal will offer
new safeguards to ensure these standards
are always met we will introduce a new
workers rights bill to ensure UK workers
enjoy rights that are every bit as good
as or better than those provided for by
EU rules and we will discuss further
amendments with trade unions and
businesses the new brexit deal will also
guarantee there will be no change in the
level of Environmental Protection when
these EU and we will establish a new
independent office of Environmental
Protection to uphold the highest
environmental standards and enforcement
clients the new Rexach deal will also
place a legal duty on the government to
seek as close to frictionless trade with
the EU in goods as possible subject to
being outside the single market and
ending freedom of movement in order to
deliver this the UK will maintain common
rules with the EU for goods and
agri-food products that are relevant
Czech supporter this will be
particularly important for our
manufacturing firms and trade unions
protecting thousands of jobs that depend
on just-in-time supply chains
the most difficult area is the question
of customs at the heart of delivering
grexit lies attention between the
strength of our ambition to seize the
new opportunities that brexit presents
and the need to protect the jobs and
prosperity that are built on
interconnected relationship with other
european economies this ambition should
not be divisive there are many people
who voted to leave who also want to
retain close trading links with Europe
just as there are many people like
myself who voted to remain a debtor
excited by the new opportunities the
brexit presents indeed I believe one of
the great opportunities of leaving the
European Union is the ability to have an
independent trade policy and to benefit
from the new jobs and industries that
can result from deepening our trade ties
with partners across every continent of
the world but I've never believed that
this should come at the expense of the
jobs and livelihoods that are sustained
by our existing trade with the EU and to
protect these both the government and
the opposition agree that we must have
as close as possible to frictionless
trade at the UK EU border now the
government has already put a proposal
which delivers the benefits of a customs
union but with the ability for the UK to
determine its own trade and development
policy neighbor are both skeptical of
our ability to negotiate that and don't
believe an independent trade policy is
in the national interest they would
prefer a comprehensive customs union
with a UK say entry entry
policy but with the EU negotiating on
our part if we're going to pass
withdrawal agreement bill and to deliver
brexit we must resolve this difference
as part of the cross party discussions
the government offered a compromise
option of a temporary customs union on
goods only including UK say in relevant
EU trade policy and an ability to change
the arrangement so a future government
could move it in its preferred direction
we were not able to agree this as part
of our cross party talks so it is right
that Parliament should have the
opportunity to resolve this during the
passage of the bill and decide between
the government's proposal and a
compromise option and so the government
will commit in law to let Parliament
decide this issue and to reflect the
outcome of this process in legislation
I've also listened carefully to those
who've been arguing for a second
referendum I've made my own view on this
be clear on many time many times I do
not believe this is a route that we
should take because I think we should be
implementing the result of the first
referendum not asking the British people
to vote in a second one but I recognize
the genuine and sincere strength of
feeling across the house on his
inflation issue the government will
therefore include in the withdrawal
agreement bill an introduction a
requirement to vote on whether to hold a
second referendum and this must take
place before the withdrawal agreement
can be ratified and if the House of
Commons were to vote for a referendum it
would be requiring the government to
make provisions for such a referendum
including legislation if it wanted to
ratify the withdrawal agreement so to
those MPs who want a second referendum
to come
the deal you need a deal and therefore
withdrawal agreement bill to make it
happen so let it have its second reading
and then make your case to Parliament
finally we cannot expect MPs to vote on
the same two documents they previously
rejected so we will seek changes to
political declaration to reflect this
commune deal so our new brexit do makes
of 10-point offer to everyone in
parliament who wants to deliver the
result of the referendum one the
government will seek to conclude
alternative arrangements to replace the
backstop high December 2020 so that it
never needs to be used to a commitment
that should the backstop come into force
the government will ensure that Great
Britain will stand aligned with warn
Ireland through the negotiating
objectives and final treaties for our
future relationship with the EU will
have to be approved by MPs for a new
workers rights bill the guarantees
workers rights will be no less favorable
than in the EU five will be no change in
the level of environmental protection
when we leave the EU six the UK will
seek as close to frictionless trade in
goods with the EU as possible while
outside the single market and ending
free movement 7 will keep up-to-date
with EU rules for goods and agri-food
products that are relevant to checks at
border protecting the thousands of jobs
that depend on just-in-time supply
chains 8 the government will bring
forward a customs compromise for MPS to
decide on to break the deadlock 9 who
will be a vote for MPs on whether the
deal should be subject to a referendum
and 10 will be a legal duty to secure
changes to the political declaration
let this new deal all of these
commitments will be guaranteed in law so
they will endure at least for this pond
the revised deal will deliver on the
result of the referendum and overly by
voting for withdrawal agreement bill
that second reading come MPs provide the
vehicle Parliament needs to determine
how we eat the EU so if MPs vote against
the second reading of this bill they are
voting to stop brexit if they do so the
consequences could hardly be greater
reject this deal and leaving the EU with
a negotiated deal any time soon will be
dead in the water and what would we do
then some suggest leaving without a deal
but whatever you think of that outcome
Parliament has been clear it will do all
it can to stop it if not No Deal that it
have to be a general election or a
second referendum that could lead to
revocation and lower exit at all who
believes that a general election at this
moment when we still not yet delivered
on what people instructed us to do is in
the national interest I do not my views
on second referendum are well known look
at what this debate is doing to our
politics extending it for months more
perhaps indefinitely risked opening the
door to a nightmare future of
permanently polarized politics look
around the world and consider the health
of liberal democrat democratic politics
and look across the United Kingdom and
consider the impact of failing to
deliver on the clear instruction of the
British people in a lawful referendum we
do not have to take that path instead we
can deliver brexit all the changes I've
set out today have the simple aim of
building support in Parliament to do
that I believe that is a majority do we
one for a brexit deal
comments by parsing a deal we can
actually get brexit done and move our
country forward if we can do so I
passionately believe that we can seize
the opportunities that I know lie ahead
the world is changing fast our young
people will enjoy enjoy opportunities in
the future that my generation could
never have dreamed of this is a great
time to be alive a great future awaits
the United Kingdom and we have all we
need as a nation to make your success if
we're trying to 20s the 2030s but we
will not do so as long as our politics
remain stuck in an endless debate on
brexit we all have to take some
responsibility for the fact that we're
in the same class and we all have a
responsibility to do what we can to get
out of it the biggest problem with
Britain today is its politics and who
can fix that with the right grexit deal
we can end this corrosive debate we can
get out of the EU political structures
the Parliament the Commission the
Council of Ministers that are
emotionalize under our own environment
back in sovereign control of our destiny
we can stop British laws being enforced
by a European Court and instead make our
own Supreme Court genuinely supreme we
can end free movement and design an
immigration system based around skills
that work for our economy and society we
can stop making vast annual payments to
the EU budget and instead instead spend
our own money our own priorities like
the NHS we can get out of the Common
Fisheries Policy in the command of
cultural policy design our own systems
around our own needs and resources we
can do all of these things and by
leaving with a deal we can do so much
more besides by reaching an agreement
with our new trading partners we can
keep tariff barriers down and goods
flowing friction-free across borders
protecting jobs and setting our firms up
the future
yes we can guarantee workers rights and
environmental protections with a deal we
can keep our close security partnerships
and keep working together to keep people
safe we can ensure that the challenge of
the bad border between Northern Ireland
to dial it is met in a way that works of
people on both sides this is a huge
opportunity for the United Kingdom out
of the EU out of ever closer Union free
to do things differently and doing so in
a way that protects jobs protects our
security maintains a close relationship
with our friends and works the whole
United Kingdom it is practical it is
responsible it is deliverable right now
it is slipping away from us we risk
losing a great opportunity this deal is
not the final word on our future
relationship with the EU it is a
stepping stone to reach that future a
future where the people of the UK
determine the road ahead for the country
we all love this deal lays the
groundwork and settles many of the core
issues but in the years ahead
Parliament will be able to debate decide
and refine the exact nature of our
relationship with the EU some will want
us to draw closer others will want to
become more different both sides can
make their case in the months and years
ahead the key thing is decisions will be
made not by any peas or Commissioners or
the EU Council but by the United Kingdom
Parliament elected by the British people
that is what being an independent nation
state is
all about those debates those decisions
are for the future what matters now is
honoring the result of the referendum
and seizing the opportunity which is
right before us so we all needed a new
offer to find common ground in
Parliament that is now the only way to
deliver brexit over the next two weeks
the government will be making the case
for this deal in Parliament and media
and in the country on what is best and
right for our country now and in the
future and on what the majority of
British people of all political
persuasions want to see happen tomorrow
I made a statement to the House of
Commons and then we opportunity is
throughout the bill for MPs on all sides
to have their say but I say with
conviction to every MP of every party I
have compromised now I asked you to
compromise to we've been given a clear
instruction by the people we are
supposed to represent so hope you find a
way to honor that instruction move our
country and our politics forward and
build the better future that all of us
want to see thank you
now the student I'm sequestrants from
the media and thank you mr. lawrence
berkeley of c-- news and as you said
that they're getting of your speech
you've had nearly three years the
opposition parties have already said
they will not vote for this deal
isn't it simply too late now for you to
be offering a compromising video please
simply don't want to listen and secondly
can you confirm that if this bill is
lost you will do well on the second part
of your question or that was last week's
news and i set out our agendas what to
what what will be happening
the on the first point that you make i
would say to every MP and I've set this
actually I'll make it straight into the
House of Commons tomorrow we will be
publishing the bill wait and look at the
details of the bill and think about the
importance of delivering brexit because
this is the way that we can ratify an
agreement and ensure that we leave the
European Union that must be at the
forefront of our thinking and as I said
I think this is the opportunity we have
to do just that so look at the details
of this bill if I say I compromised I
think I asked others to compromise too
so that together we can do what the
British people voted for in the
referendum and we really do that's Prime
Minister whatever happens now with your
brexit bill you have promised to stand
down
as Prime Minister would you like to see
a brexit ear replace you or do you think
that that would just prolong the
polarization of politics that you've
just spoken off nice try best but my
view is I'm not going to comment on the
future a future leadership reduction
that will be a matter for the
Conservative Party in all of its parts
I see let's see
sorry I'll give you my solution places
are where you said you said but you will
give me the opportunity to vote on
whether to have a so-called confirmatory
referendum does that mean you are giving
a commitment that if they vote for that
referendum there will be a referendum
and you also said look you will give any
they vote on whether the UK should
remain in a permanent customs union
without the ability to negotiate trade
deals with other countries again is this
a commitment that if they vote for that
that is what a Conservative government
would negotiate was I said in the speech
obviously and as we take these issues
through the through the House of Commons
what the House of Commons will be saying
is what they want to see in the in the
final bill and if you want a deal it's
about ratifying the bill but I do have
to pick you up Robert on in fact that
you said that I had said there would be
a compromise solution of a permanent
customs union on the table no I didn't I
said a temporary customs union which
would enable a future government to take
the Russkies arrangement in whichever
direction it wished wish to do so
Francis
for instance over from the times you've
taken a case to the country over the
next two weeks there are elections on
Thursday when we actually see the bill
37 clauses and the new are you
committing to publishing the bill before
recess we'll be publishing the bill in
the next few days and as I say I would
ask people to wait and look at the
details of what is in the bill and as I
say this is the opportunity that people
have to deliver on brexit what does the
bill do it enables us to get out of
there EU it enables us to take that
control of our money our borders and our
laws and that's what people voted for
that's what this bill would enable
people to do
maybe courier from the mirror and Prime
Minister you came into number 10 i'ma
sing to deliver brexit and to put the
issue of Europe to bed wants to prove
Conservative Party how successful do you
think you've been in doing that well
patiently obviously I just said my
speech I haven't connected it for exit
this is about what I'm doing today is
about setting out what I believe is a
new brexit deal that can command
majority across the House of Commons and
that can enable us to do just that
because it's not just my responsibility
to deliver brexit I believe it's the
responsibility of the whole of the House
of Commons to deliver that grexit we
gave the British people the choice in
the referendum the House of Commons and
the government at the time trading would
abide by the decision the House of
Commons vote each trigger article 50 the
House of Commons passed the initial
withdrawal Act that set the scene for us
being able to withdraw when he had a
deal and the legislation would be new
legislation will be necessary to put
that deal into place and now we have the
opportunity while confirming that brexit
by passing this by passing this bill
I'll take one last question from Jason
chasing ghosts in the Daily Mail some of
your colleagues seem to be opposed to
this not because necessarily what's in
it but because it's you who's doing the
asking what do you say to those who now
think it's your duty and international
interest for you to step aside and let
someone else have a go before this whole
thing is even worse on the on that issue
of myself as I said to Jinora
you know the situation as I said have as
we said last week following my
discussions with try and channel 22 look
I say this isn't just about me if it was
just about me and how I voted we don't
read have left the European Union
actually this is about a responsibility
across the whole of the House of Commons
for us to come together and find a way
onto of delivering on the instruction
people gave us people want us to leave
the EU we need to deliver that this deal
enables the House of Commons to do that
to come together to support the
withdrawal agreement and ensure that we
leave the European Union thank you
[Applause]